Bienvenido a la segunda parte
de la presentación de funciones.
En este vídeo vamos a continuar
donde nos quedamos en el anterior.
De hecho, todavía estoy un poquito apenado
por ese ejemplo de la comida y de los vídeos
fue un poco extraño,
pero espero que te haya ayudado.
En fin, el chiste es que
ahorita vamos a hacer más problemas,
para que veas que esto de los problemas de funciones
incluso hasta puede ser divertido.
Bueno, este problema dice lo siguiente,
tenemos la función "g",
definida de la siguiente manera
"g" de "x"
es igual a...
iba a ser una función definida por casos...
va a ser igual a 1 si "x" es par...
es par,
y va a ser igual a 0 si "x" es impar...
es impar...
impar, muy bien, además de esta función "g"
vamos a considerar una función "f" de "x",
y ésta "f" de "x" está dada así,
como "x" más 3 veces "g" de "x".
Muy bien, ahora teniendo estas dos funciones,
imagínate que nos piden evaluar "f" de 5.
¿Qué tendríamos que hacer
para obtener "f" de 5?
Ah, pues este 5 tenemos que sustituirlo
en cada lugar donde aparezca "x" en esta expresión, porque eso es "f" de 5,
entonces vamos a hacer esto.
Entonces aquí esta "x"
tenemos que cambiarla por un 5,
y luego tenemos que sumar tres veces "g",
de...
y aquí hay que ponerle "g" de 5...
"g" de 5...
¿sale?
bueno,
¿ahora qué tenemos que hacer?
Bueno, pues podríamos seguir desarrollando,
pero primero tenemos que determinar quién es "g" de 5.
¿Cómo le hacemos para determinar g de 5?
Ah,
pues ahora metemos 5 en la reglita de acá.
"g" de 5 ¿qué sería?
Pues bueno, ¿5 es par?
No.
¿5 es impar? Sí, 5 es impar,
entonces "g" de 5...
"g" de 5
es igual a 0
y por lo tanto aquí tendríamos 5 más 3 por 0,
esto sería un 0
y por lo tanto aquí tendríamos 5.
Vale, entonces
"f" de 5 es igual a 5,
pero ahora,
imagina que nos piden determinar "f" de 6...
"f" de 6.
Bueno, pues misma idea,
aquí tenemos que sustituir "x" por 6,
ponemos 6 más...
tres veces...
tres veces "g" de
6.
Ok,
esto de aquí es igual a,
6 más 3 por "g" de 6
y ahora, ¿cuánto es "g" de 6?
Pues una vez más,
tenemos que ir aquí a la función "g"
vemos si 6 es par o impar,
es par,
entonces estamos en este caso,
y entonces g de 6 es igual a 1.
Vale,
entonces quedaría 6 más 3 por 1,
3 por 1 es 3, así que simplemente nos queda
6 más 3 que es igual a 9.
Muy bien,
creo que con esto ya vamos agarrándole
un poco más la onda a esto de las funciones ¿verdad?
Es muy sencillo,
simplemente si queremos evaluar una función
pues cambiamos...
pues cada una de las "x" que encontramos,
por el número en el cual queremos evaluar.
Bueno, vamos a hacer un ejemplo un poco más difícil,
ahora con tres funciones.
Imagínate que nos dan la función  "f" de "x"
y nos dicen que es igual a
"x" cuadrada más 1,
nos da en la función "g" de "x"
y nos dicen que es igual a, no sé, le voy a poner,
2x más "f" de "x" menos 3...
"x" menos 3,
y finalmente nos dan la función "h" de "x"
y "h" de "x"
es igual a 5 veces...
pues 5 veces "x",
más...
no nada más así,
5 veces "x" ¿vale?
Entonces ahora tenemos tres funciones,
vamos a resolver algunos problemas.
Imagínate que nos piden encontrar,
pues no sé, vamos a ponerle "h"
déjame agarrar otro color un poco más bonito...
voy a agarrar este azul...
Entonces imagínate que nos piden determinar,
"h" de "g" de 3.
Ok, esto ya se ve un poco más complicado
¿verdad?
vas a decir,
¿cómo le hago para encontrar "h" de "g" de 3?
Bueno, pues vamos paso a paso.
Lo primero que tenemos que hacer es
determinar "g" de 3,
entonces eso es lo primerito.
¿Cómo ya hacemos para encontrar "g" de 3?
Pues nos vamos a la definición de "g".
Y tenemos que sustituir las "x",
todas las que aparezcan por un 3.
Entonces esta "x" se hace 3,
ésta "x" se hace 3 y ésta de acá también
entonces nos quedaría, a ver,
"g" de 3...
"g" de 3
es igual a 2 por 3
2 por 3 es 6
más "f" de 3 menos 3.
3 menos 3 es 0,
así que sería "f" de 0.
Todavía no terminamos con determinar "g" de 3,
porque ahora tenemos que ver,
quién es "f" de 0 para sustituirlo aquí.
Entonces ahora nos vamos a "f",
vamos a la definición de "f" sería 6 más
y ¿quién es "f" de cero?
Pues es, elevar al cuadrado el número,
es "x" al cuadrado y sumarle 1.
Nos quedaría 6 más 0 más 1
y entonces "g" de 3 es igual a
siete, ¿vale?
Ok,
entonces "g" de 3 es igual a 7.
Y bueno, ahora con esto,
ya podemos poner "g" de 3 acá,
nos quedaría "h" de 7...
"h" de 7...
y "h" de 7
lo podemos calcular directamente,
nos vamos aquí,
"h" de 7 es 5 por 7
ó lo que es lo mismo
7 por 5,
que es igual a 35,
¿vale?
Entonces parecía un poco complicado esta expresión, pero simplemente lo fuimos haciendo por cachitos,
aquí adentro teníamos un "g" de 3,
hacemos primero ese "g" de 3,
para eso nos vamos a la expresión de "g"
ponemos aquí el 3,
nos queda 2 por 3 = 6,
pero luego hay que ver quién es "f" de 3 menos 3,
o sea "f" de 0
"f" de 0
y bueno viendo "f",
nos queda que "f" de cero es 1
y por lo tanto es
6 más 1 que nos da 7.
Bueno,
vamos a hacer otro ejemplo más.
De hecho ya no tengo tanto espacio abajo,
vamos a hacer otro ejemplo
con estas mismas funciones ¿vale?
De hecho eso hasta ayuda,
porque así no tenemos que  sacar nuevas funciones
y no va a ser tan confuso.
Bueno, entonces vamos a hacer otro ejemplo
con estas mismas funciones,
entonces imagínate
que nos piden determinar "f"...
"f"...
no sé, "f" de "h" de 10,
por decir algo ¿vale?
Entonces "f" de "h" de 10.
Misma idea, lo primero que tenemos que hacer es
determinar quiénes "h" de 10,
lo que está dentro del paréntesis,
pues más interno ¿vale?
Entonces "h" de 10
¿cuánto es?
"h" de "x" es "5x",
entonces "h" de 10
es 5 por 10,
por lo tanto "h" de 10,
perdón "h" de...
¡Sí! "h" de 10,
"h" de 10 es igual a 50.
entonces aquí nos quedaría,
"f" de 50,
¿vale?
y luego,
¿quién es "f" de 50?
pues el 50 lo ponemos acá,
nos quedaría 50 al cuadrado más 1,
50 al cuadrado es 2500
y por lo tanto el resultado sería 2501 ¿vale?
2501,
éste estuvo fácil,
vamos a hacer uno más.
No sé,
imagínate que nos piden determinar...
nos piden determinar,
"g" de "h" de 1
¿va?
entonces "g" de "h" de 1.
De hecho hay dos formas
en las cuales podríamos hacer esto,
primero usando la definición de "g"
y luego la de "h"
pero vamos a hacerlo así
como lo estamos haciendo,
empezando con "h".
Entonces tenemos que ver quién es "h" de 1.
Esto sería igual a "g" de
y a ver, "h" de 1...
"h" de 1 es 5 por 1 ,
entonces es igual a g de 5.
¡Muy bien!
ya nada más tenemos que ver quién es "g" de 5,
entonces "g" de 5 es igual a...
nos vamos aquí,
"g" de 5 es, 2 por 5 que sería 10,
más "f" de 5 menos 3,
5 menos 3 es 2,
entonces nos quedaría más "f" de 2
y por lo tanto,
esto sería igual a 10 más...
vamos a ver quién es "f" de 2
"f" de 2,
es igual a 2 al cuadrado,
que es 4 más 1
o sea "f" de 2 es 5,
sería 10 más 5
y por lo tanto el resultado es igual a 15.
Excelente,
bueno,
no te preocupes,
si todavía estás confundido,
en los siguientes vídeos,
voy a a grabar todavía más ejercicios,
para que podamos ir aprendiendo más
acerca de las funciones.
Bueno,
nos vemos hasta la próxima.